we're starting today with the president
yes the president joe biden who is
showing more signs of life than we've
seen for months from the standpoint of
his presidency joe biden riding high on
a number of major accomplishments went
to wilkes-barre pennsylvania yesterday
and he absolutely crushed republicans
republicans who are now openly
threatening violence we covered two days
ago republican senator lindsey graham
saying if trump is indicted there will
be riots in the street yeah it'll be
trumpists rioting in the streets we know
lindsay
and joe biden with i i have to say i
you know i'm not adding a value judgment
to this
but joe biden more fired up and
energetic i would argue that i have seen
him his entire presidency as we are now
just weeks from the 2022 midterms on
which so much ride
take a look at this let me say this to
my mag of republican friends in congress
yeah
don't tell me you support law
enforcement
if you won't condemn what happened on
the sixth right don't tell me
right
can't do it
for god's sake whose side are you on not
long whose side are you on
[Applause]
look
[Applause]
simple you're on the side of a mob
for the side of the police you can't be
pro-law enforcement and pro-insurrection
you can't be a party of law and order
and call the people who attacked the
police on january 6 patriots right you
can't do it
what are we teaching our children
it's just that simple
and now it's sickening
to see the new attacks in the fbi
threaten the life of law enforcement
agents and their families for simply
carrying out the law and doing their job
look
listen
um we saw this type of thing
from california governor gavin newsom
about a month ago and i told you that
without endorsing his entire political
world view
that it was the exact right approach to
dealing with these modern mega
republicans
democrats have to be aggressive
democrats in some cases have to be
ruthless it doesn't mean we do the
things they do we don't tell lies we
don't deal
but we have to adopt
this approach
and democrats should be looking at the
approach that gavin newsom is taking
democrats should be looking at this
particular version of joe biden and can
just think about the opposite for a
second imagine if you had
democrats
openly threatening law enforcement in
the way that republicans have done after
january january 6th excuse me after the
search warrant being carried out at
mar-a-lago just the republicans would be
saying forget about due process throw
him in prison for life and i was glad to
also see joe biden call out lindsey
graham lindsey graham who
predicted by which i mean
threatened
or promised
riots if donald trump were to be
indicted it's a great thing that joe
biden is going right after him as well
no one expects politics to be a patty
cake
they sometimes get mean as hell
but the idea you turn on the television
and see senior senators and congressmen
saying if such and such happens
there will be blood in the street
where the hell are we right and of
course a direct reference there to
lindsey graham
this is
a much more interesting joe biden look
at the joe biden of the last three
months number one rhetorically fiery
again energetic
accomplished more during his covet
isolation than trump did his entire
presidency if you can imagine that and
now we see a great jobs report inflation
is down gas prices are down the
inflation reduction act has been passed
the pact act the infrastructure i mean i
could go on and on i'm not going to give
you the full list every single time but
accomplishment after accomplishment
after accomplishment this is a very
different joe biden than we saw earlier
in the presidency or sort of in the
middle of the presidency and it's also a
democratic party whose chances in
november of 2022 are looking
dramatically better so we're going to
follow it very closely and by the way in
the middle of all of this
we are seeing
some republicans some republicans
so disgusted
by the low quality candidates that their
primary voters have selected to
represent them in november
that in some races republicans are
increasingly endorsing democrats and
that's what we're going to talk about
next here's something fun for labor day
our sponsor established titles is a
project based on the historic scottish
custom where landowners are called lords
and ladies established titles allows you
to ceremonially purchase as little as a
square foot of dedicated land in
edelston scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or lady you get an
official certificate with a crest they
let you see exactly where your plot is
located and here's really the cool part
a tree is planted for every plot of land
sold established titles also does really
great work with organizations doing
environmental work all over the world
like one tree planted and trees for the
future so it's a fun gift but you're
also supporting something great which is
the real gift you're helping to preserve
the picturesque woodlands in
biodiversity of scotland and supporting
global reforestation efforts it makes a
great last-minute gift they even have
couple packs that come with adjoining
plots of land established titles is
giving my audience ten percent off when
you go to establish titles dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below